closer and closer to cloudy making a
decision
that's where that urgency came from for
other teams to say
we we we want clowning we don't want him
on another team we want this disruptive
force of nature on our team and i think
that's why there was a sense that more
teams were coming to the table not less
as he got closer to making a decision
well yeah i mean mike i mean how many
you know first off he's a guy screw the
stats when you talk about your debian
cloudy he is he's he's one of the kings
of f up the playstat that we talk about
so much i mean we saw it last year we've
seen it his whole career there's not a
lot of physical forces in football like
gideon county and you know i even i got
into this with a few people on twitter
over the weekend you know again it just
goes to the bottom line like whoa
it's only three sacks it's only six
sacks yeah i understand that there's
more to the game than sax i mean i just
heard a defensive coach last week
talking about he'd rather have defensive
ends and outside linebackers you get
quarterback pressures over sacks they
affect the game more but regardless
that's why he's high commodity you know
you could play him all over the field he
can stand up and rush from anywhere he
can play defensive tackle he can play
defensive end he can play outside
linebacker and drop back into pass
coverage so he really is so versatile
and i understand teams wanting a guy
like him you and i have sat there in awe
over his physical ability at times
before and i think that's what teams
like about him and seeing them and
that's why tennessee wanted him so bad
and it's a shame how it worked out for
judavian clowney throughout the off
season his camp refused anything in the
range of 15 million on a one-year deal
and waited and waited for it to get
better it never got better at the end of
the day he had to take what he could get
this deal with the titans is worth
up to 15 million dollars i've heard
different opinions on how easily the 15
million can be achieved but the bottom
line is the base amount is less than 15.
i've heard 12
some are saying as low as 10 with a a
very easy jump to 12 and a much harder
climb to 15.
we'll see this is one of those where you
have to wait for the paperwork and
because of the holiday weekend the
paperwork is going to be backlogged a
little bit but it'll be interesting to
see that final contract because this is
a guy who ultimately
even if he hits every incentive and does
everything the contract requires he's
going to get to a spot where he had
previously said no he said no to 15
million right earlier in the year now
his best case scenario is 15 and and
also as we reported over the weekend the
titans have agreed not to use the
franchise tag next year on geneva and
cloudy so if he does have that big year
hits all of his incentives is healthy at
the end of the year which was a big
problem this past year then he sets
himself up to hit the market again and
get paid he hasn't gotten that long-term
deal yet no we've talked about that
before is he going to be a carpet bagger
like in dominican sue who just signs
one-year deals after one year deals
i'm told he wants a place where he can
he can settle down and it can be home
for him sure and that was one of the
reasons why he picked the titans in new
orleans the thinking was this is a
one-year all-in move in tennessee this
is about to deviant clowney hopefully
sticking around for the long haul and
being the guy he's never been the guy
think about it chris j.j watt was the
guy in houston bobby wagner's the guy in
seattle if you go to new orleans cam
jordan is the guy you go to tennessee
who's the guy the guy's javian clown
right no you're right and you know the
the other thing is there's history there
right i mean jedevian county drafted by
the houston texans you know you
mentioned it yeah that's been the
biggest contract he's seen which we know
rookie contracts still really good money
that's awesome you know but yes he's not
seen that you know second okay i'm going
to be able to set up my family for the
rest of their lives and have job
security that way no he's he's going to
be i think a one-year carpetbagger a
little to what you're saying i think a
lot of the times mike we'll see maybe he
can start something here in tennessee
with a guy like mike vrabel who values
the position this is a defense that's
missed this position dearly as far as
guys that could come off the edge and be
a physical force and disrupt and do that
that was one of the biggest issues with
the tennessee titans last year that's
why patrick mahomes was sitting back
there for seven and eight seconds in the
afc championship game they have no guys
that can win one-on-one match-ups when
it comes when it came to just rushing
the passer harold landry showed a little
uh potential in that last year i think
he's a guy that can continue to be
better but yeah mike i think he might be
able to carve us
of all the spots he might be able to
carve a spot out for himself here with
the tennessee titans i i do and then
yeah go ahead what go ahead now that
mike brabel connection is huge it's huge
it's huge because
he's a very loyal guy
he's a very trusting guy once you're
inside what you would call the trust
tree and vrabel still is and i think
that was a huge draw for genevieve and
clowney to reunite with mike vrable and
go to a place where
there's a chance it won't just be a
one-year thing
everywhere else it was feeling like a
one-year thing in comparison to what it
could be with the tennessee titans now
ideally he has the kind of a year that
forces the titans to pay him a lot of
money next year to keep him around but
that's what the hope is and that was one
of the big factors in clowney choosing
to go to tennessee also frankly
one of the factors one of the draws one
of the attractions playing the texans
twice a year these guys are still human
and when you consider that the texans
made him the first overall pick in 2014
and never rewarded him with that second
contract after the 2016 season
maybe that's when they should have
signed him to a long-term deal like they
did with j.j water after his third year
in the nfl well but they made javi and
clowney finish his five-year rookie
contract and then applied the franchise
tag and never offered him anything that
he thought was sufficient on a long-term
deal and waited and waited and waited
and waited and then it was all very
rushed at the end and that was one of
the other factors too and that's why you
know there was a report early saturday
night
that he had picked tennessee and then
there were disputes i'm told that that
was it was not final
when the report first came out that he
picked tennessee that it just ended up
being tennessee at the end of the day he
felt like it was rushed last year when
the signing trade happened with the
texans to the seahawks and he was
feeling rushed this year and he slammed
the brakes on it and the saints were
still in play
and the seahawks were still in play and
the ravens were still to a certain
extent in play although they fell off
once we got into saturday and once one
of the things we're going to talk about
coming up was not a possibility but he
he slowed it down saturday night and he
wanted to know what he was getting
himself into he wanted to make the right
decision he didn't want to just rush
into something where there was a chance
he didn't fit and he believed he didn't
really fit in seattle and he still had a
great year when he was healthy right can
you imagine how good he's going to be in
a place where he feels like he fits well
that's that's where i was going to go
with this and i'm glad you brought it up
because i do i think this is scheme fit
too it's about him looking at it and
again i think that's the mike vrable
connection it's the three-four new
england defense i can be an outside
linebacker when we're in base defense i
can play defensive end when we go to a
four down front and play that style of
football mike frable's got great
familiarity of course with that role
he's going to be able to teach you know
a guy like jodevion cloudy and stay on
top of him with his techniques and how
to play this position or this defensive
technique the right way so i think all
that may you know make sense and i think
you know to what you're saying mike
about a guy in jedevian clowney who's
trying to hunker down and kind of find
his spot because you're right he was
kind of becoming the guy with the
houston texans but
hey i understand it it's hard to give a
guy like deviant clowney in his injury
history a long-term deal with a lot of
guaranteed money and that's going to be
the issue for him here going forward but
i do think between
the need for a player the head coach the
scheme fit all of that makes sense and
the fact that i don't think they really
have a household name in their front
seven and now they do
uh it makes you look at the tennessee
titans in a different light now that
he's he's on that defense
and it's amazing because i still think
most fans just look at the titans and
kind of shrug this is a team that made
it to the final four last year they were
up 10 points twice in the first half
against the kansas city chiefs they paid
to keep running back derrick henry
around they paid to keep quarterback
ryan tannehill around and now they've
paid although not as much as they would
have had to earlier this year to get
jadavian clowney in town and we still
look at them when we kind of shrug
there's this sense all ryan hill's going
to get injured all derek henry now that
he's gotten paid he's not going to be
very good i mean that's not what we
believe that's just kind of that vague
sense out there that that last year was
that planets lined up
luck
intervened and that's the best you're
ever going to be and you're not going to
do it again this year and i think
anybody who believes that doesn't
understand mike vrable and doesn't
understand the quality of the players
that they have quietly amassed there and
now you put genevieve and clowny on top
of that tennessee's the one team
remember we talked last week hey what if
the vikings had gotten to davey and
clown instead of yannick and gawker and
you're like holy crap
the titans are the one team that isn't
going to spark that widespread holy crap
reaction and maybe it's the one that
should spark it the most no i i mean
you're right it's not a team that just
absolutely lights up the national fan
base that way
you know i get it and you know
i understand it
i'm not so sure like i i everything you
said about the titans mike vrabel right
i got tremendous confidence in him i
think he's a hell of a football coach
but i guess there's still
unanswered things about their team where
i'm i'm even a little you know i'm
getting to that point of the year where
we're gonna have to pick our team to go
to the playoffs right mike and win
divisions and who's gonna go to the
super bowl tennessee's one of those
teams i do look at and just go man i
just don't have a feel for them you know
again it is year two with arthur smith
and ryan tannehill can they dominate the
line of scrimmage like they did at the
end of the year last year with derek
henry i don't know jack conklin's gone
you know the secondary yeah there's some
talent there but they didn't perform
great last year yeah could somebody on
the front seven show up i mean it's just
i guess i have questions is what i'm
saying it's a hard team to get a feel
for it be a team that i much would have
loved to have seen in pre-season one
more time just to get another feel for
oh what have they added to their offense
and their scheme and what does this team
look like because i think i'm a little
with the public i don't know quite how
to feel with them i think you're a
little bit more bullish on them than i
am
they've and i think they enjoy that
vague sense that no one really you know
that that's the best thing a coach can
trip into and you can't engineer that
you just hope that it happens where
your team isn't pegged as a hot team as
a team to watch for the super bowl
because number one that keeps your
players from getting a big head and
number two it gives you something to
kick them in the butt with to get them
motivated nobody believes in you that's
a powerful powerful motivator to get
guys to do everything they need to do to
check all the boxes they need to check
and to go out there every week with that
edge with that attitude that they're
trying to prove people wrong if you can
make that happen and every coach wants
something like that and plenty of
coaches will try to fabricate something
like that
if you have that fall into your lap it's
perfect and the titans are the team in
the afc this year that i think are are
in that category where
no one expects anything out of them no
one really respects what they did last
year and mike vrabel learning from the
master playing for bill belichick how to
go about getting the most out of that in
a locker room because belichick very
good at that and understands that again
human beings in those uniforms and they
react the way the rest of us do and if
you can find a way to push their buttons
it's going to work all right let's
change gears here slightly to the story
behind the story and
it first came out on sunday
that the saints were trying a creative
way
and it reminded me of the browns
essentially buying a second round pick
from
the houston texans a few years ago when
they picked up the brock osweiler
contract basically for 15 million
dollars it ended up being the net amount
15 million in cash and cap space they
got a second round pick by taking on the
brock osweiler contract via trade it was
a trade that sent
brock osweiler plus a second round pick
to the browns not brock osweiler for a
second round
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports